SPEAKER: The Cloud
Architecture Quest
provides hands-on lab
practice on topics
related to the Associate Cloud
Engineer Certification exam.
Click Enroll in this
quest to get started.
Beginning with the Cloud
IAM Qwik Start Lab,
complete all labs in this Quest.
Make sure to review related
product documentation that
is linked from the
lab instructions.
The Qwiklabs catalog has
hundreds of self-paced labs
on various topics.
It is highly recommended
that you complete the labs
in the GCP Essentials
Quest and more
to get additional
hands-on practice.
Remember, the more you
practice, the more proficient
you will be in the topics
related to the Associate Cloud
Engineer Certification exam.
When you complete
Qwiklabs quests,
you will receive Qwiklabs
badges that you can showcase on
your LinkedIn or
social media profile
to highlight your
accomplishments
to potential employers.